meeting was quite entertaining uh I mean
there is quite a lot to talk about
um it was quite late to be honest it was
a 6 PM UTC time and then the press
conference I have six so it finished
around quarter past seven and at the end
you only have like two hours of price
action in the New York session
um really what usually happens is that
it feels imbalances because if you go to
the 50 minutes time frame this is a
pattern that you see in almost every FMC
meeting we talked about this in
yesterday's video I hear some uh posted
about it
but usually what you see it's a false
move right at the start when the data
gets released so this can happen a lot
to the upside or the alarm side in black
is yesterday was to the upside you can
see this week over here they went to 27
300 that's the first move then you see
the drop
during the press conference okay
and then you have
the retrace because if you notice it
leaves some liquidity pools behind check
for example this huge liquidity pulley
lives there and here that's also another
one so you can see then how price tends
to retrace those two liquidity pools or
those imbalances that they press
conference lives and at the end of the
day what happened in the fomc meeting
is that you have a false move
manipulation
and then the retrace of those imbalances
and at the end look that's nine o'clock
UTC time New York session finishes and
nothing really happened so you have to
wait for the next day to see the real
move
and that is the real move to the
downside why well because Jerome Powell
who was I would say very Hokies okay
there was a lot of things first of all
the interest rate decision it wasn't a
surprise everybody was expecting the
same that it's a pause in rates
so that was priced in and the market
didn't move based on that but in the Dot
Plot they were still projecting a new
hike this year of 25 basis points now
that could happen either in November or
in December and I've said this I think
I'm even I'm one month ago that I was
expecting
the FED to hold rates now in that
meeting and in the next meeting in
November to hike 25 basis points because
this is what they've done previously
this year they've basically done that
they post then they hike enough they've
post so the next thing is probably a new
hike all right so that's what we're
expecting why well basically because
next month they're gonna get first the
CPI data and we're expecting that it
comes quite hot
hang on that's not my chart is it
this is my chart oh yeah because I'm
David I'm from there okay this is the
gasoline prices and you can see that in
August yearly went up less than two
percent but so far this month and we
still have another week to go
so far we are up seven percent and we've
even got to ten percent this month and
we still have one week more so why not
who do we get
293 dollars a barrel still in the next
week okay and that would be an increase
of a 12 percent
in the oil prices so of course API next
month should come quite hot I think will
probably be
um around four percent or higher CPI and
that could be the justification for the
FED to in to hike again 25 basis points
okay that's what we're expecting in
November that the FED high is 25 pesos
points also according to the Dot Plot
but this year there is one more hike
left and also
that was now everything in the Dot Plot
because also it was saying that next
year in 2024 they are expecting a
terminal rate target of five to one
percent versus the four to six percent
that they were protecting in the
previous Dot Plot so that's you know an
increase of 0.
which means that they are really
planning to keep the rates higher
for longer the famous higher for longer
quote so that's what they are projecting
and that means that the economy is going
to be uh under serious pressure if they
are going to keep the interest rates uh
high for that long because I think now
they're expecting rate goods from
September
personally I believe that this will
change
and it'll be before that but we'll see
but I still think I'd probably be uh
still before that to be honest I don't
know if it's going to be in summer or in
the spring but I'm expecting a rate good
a lot earlier than September but anyway
we'll see what happens there
um if all of this wasn't enough
the best thing to me was in the press
conference this was one of the and the
most important things of the day
they asked you on power it's a soft
Landing still the Baseline expectation
like the is the primary
projection or a scenario that you are
projecting or that you are expecting
he said no no
I wouldn't say that but I wouldn't do
that
um that means that they think that the
soft Landing is still possible
but possible of course you know you're
never gonna say that's impossible
because even if it's one or two one two
three percent chances
um he didn't say what the possibilities
or the probabilities for him would be I
wouldn't really know that but
definitely lights are possible but
unlikely basically so if it's not soft
land then you have a hard Landing
or a really bad recession so
um let's see what happens
both indefinitely 2024 is going to be
potentially a bad year for the stocks
okay and now uh maybe one day I'll do a
video of the stocks in higher time frame
uh with my targets well it's true that
I'm expecting a serious drop for the SMP
in the next uh six six months probably
even even lower four to six months all
right
so that's basically what happened
yesterday in the info MC
now there is a pattern that plays out in
almost every fomc meeting
and if you go to the 15 minutes time
frame you're gonna be able to see it I
also mentioned about this pattern in
yesterday's video
and I also uh posted on Twitter about
this book basically what you usually see
is a force move right at the start when
the data gets released that was to the
upside with this week to 27 300. and
then when the press conference started
so the press conference started around
here
you can see that then price dropped
leaves big liquidity pools behind you
have here one and two and then what
price loses is reverse those two
liquidity pools
okay so that is basically what happened
you can see that liquidity pools you got
one here that that big red candle
another Wonder
and then you can see them price
recovering
those candles
okay and with that finished to be honest
that was at quarter past nine New York
session finishes and there is not much
more room uh for more price action so at
the end of the day
nothing really happens okay because you
know you have some manipulation here
some recoveries of those imbalances and
then the price action finishes so that's
why we closed the Candlestick the daily
counter stick above the daily 50ma but
the real move happened the next day
because again fomc it was very late so
uh there was not much room for New York
to move Christ all right
now you can see the one or time frame
and this for the day Traders
you can see how price has basically
broke out below the 1 out of 50 Main
so here you have some kind of imbalances
also okay you have this liquidity pool
here
um you could even say this candle here
but
I'm only going to mention this big red
candle okay so that's the liquidity pool
in the chart now if you go to check what
the systems did and we go to the 15
minutes time frame
let's try to make some sense of what
it's currently going on with Bitcoin
okay so first of all
let's try to Mark the sessions
so
you got here
Asia
let's see
and Asia finished
around here
okay so that's not much difference in
price it's a hundred dollars okay so
this will be maybe a zero to five
percent
49 okay
so you can see that Asia
held I would say
now hang on let me remove the 150 main
now let's take what London did well
London has clearly don't price
clearly clearly doing price okay that is
London
so you know if Asia held
a London dump
what is ninja going to do well
I think that there is a serious chance
that New York reverses this move
if I'm honest with you okay
that's what I think now let's let's
please put the the right colors because
otherwise this is not gonna play out
and it's going to be the fault of the
color so
let's get this so you basically would
have here let me Mark this well for you
um
Asia holds
then you have
London Dooms
and your verses
okay so that is what we are potentially
looking for today
that's the pattern based on the trading
sessions okay Asia holds
London drops
and then maybe we can see New York
reversing
all right now for our time frame why
it's going on with the 4r50ma well hang
on actually we could do a little trick
here
and is to set
the 50ma to solely of the four of time
frame
why it's not working
there you go so you can see that we are
running up below the 4 Hour 50mate now
could this be our deviation below the
50ma because you can see that we hold it
a support here pretty well
drop
basically right before the new year
session starts that could be the stop
room that we are seeing now
and then maybe New York can reverse this
liquidity pool over here the imbalance
basically all the way
the
26930 okay that is what I'm uh aiming
today as a potential day trade and then
in terms of the on bigger time frame
then it's quite concerning
so
let me get up there hang on no I don't
want I want basically the chart there
in the time frame that I'm on okay so
you can see that we are you know
breaking below the daily 50ma
which means that maybe what could
potentially happen next is that the next
daily candle comes and recovers this
candle here and test the daily 50mm
resistance and then next week we could
see lower prices if that is the case
then you want to see also the weekly
candle closing on Sunday
let me remove this
closing on Sunday below the quickly 50
May okay
if we get those two things
both the daily candles
below the 50 May and the quickly candle
did of the 50ma next week
we're going to favor shorts
okay all right and I want that to be
clear
it doesn't make any sense to open longs
below resistance
okay so that's what I'm telling you if
you can close the quickly candle below
the 50 Main and also like several daily
candles below the 50ma and the mid-range
then it's likely that we visit again the
rain slows next week okay so that's
pretty much everything that I'm looking
in the charts and now I would like to go
to high blood capital and check the
liquidations
let's check the liquidation levels first
uh I usually do this first the
liquidation levels and then I go into
the heat map because sometimes the
liquidation levels can give you a big
clue of why it might be going on with
the delta okay the Delta is selling
three to five billion dollars worth of
shore liquidations is not much
usually see reversals where where there
is more liquidity to get taken
if you notice here in this chart look at
the spikes in the other right where do
you see them
I see them to the upside
okay it's true that here you have one
a pink one here that's I think 25
leveraged Longs so you go there
one exactly let me Mark it
I think it's around here
let me see if I find it
hang on let's do this
okay so it's extracted to this one here
uh
26 400.
but you also got another one here at 26
000. 400 or 380 so they're pretty much
in that zone that we could even see New
York dropping all the way here and then
reversing to hit the that's back then
okay that would be the
the last entry
that I would take
before saying um my ideas invalidated
okay
because you can then see how to the
upside we have a lot of spikes check
this out a twenty six thousand sorry
that's not right
there at 26 700 years ago got some
liquidations at twenty seven thousand
and at twenty seven thousand two hundred
so
you can see how the liquidity is mainly
to the upside if we check the
liquidation levels but there is a chance
that we even go today all the way to 26
400.
if there is a new stophunt before
reversing okay if that's the case now
let's go to the liquidation hit Maps
okay I just posted our tweet about this
liquidation hit maps and I was saying
that
today we were going to hit one of these
two levels
and we have here 26575
we hit it to consider
and then we also have some liquidations
all the way at 27 175. now I've only
today we're gonna go all the way here if
there is an easier reversal I'm not
going to Target this level I'm going to
Target the candle the liquidity pool
that I've mentioned I think it was a
2650 okay that's what I'm targeting
but you can see that that could have
been the stopwatch already happening
okay now seven days time frame
to go a lot of liquidations uh 26 150
and 27 600.
um I think we're gonna come to one of
these levels next week
but in terms of day trading I'm
interested in checking this so I'm gonna
ignore those
one month time frame
still a lot of liquidity to the upside
too far away twenty eight thousand is
too far from for me
and in three months time frame
uh around 23 400 23 600 so again
in the midterm or in a higher time frame
I'm still expecting this level to get
hit
okay now in how long how long could
could it take until we hit this level
I don't think it's gonna take less than
two weeks
if I'm honest with you so
um you're not gonna hear me talking
about this level next week
but maybe in two three weeks we might be
approaching to this level okay that's
what I think unless if we start to go
into the into the rains highs 28 000 and
then who knows we might even break high
and go again to 31k or 32k who knows but
so far this is what I'm saying there's a
range guys uh we are right now at the
mid-range
let's see how we close the candle this
week but if we close again below the 50
Maiden I believe that there is a higher
chance that we go again to 25 000. where
the rain slows are
and anytime that you visit the range
lows there is a possibility that you
have a breakout to the downside and you
come to this Zone okay but again don't
worry I'm not saying this target to get
hidden to get hit
in the very short term we might still
take two three weeks who knows maybe in
a couple of months okay but that's
basically everything that I'm seeing in
the chat guys
we don't have really more news
announcements this week
um we've only had the fomc so at the end
it has really been a quiet week I would
say because Monday Tuesday we had
nothing now today is Thursday we'll have
nothing and tomorrow we have nothing
really so
um let's play the chart don't worry
about news announcements and focus on
the chart and risk management okay
so thank you so much guys for watching
let's hope that New York can print a
reversal
hopefully and I'll see you soon